hey what is up guys cheap phones are
getting good and good phones are getting
cheap think about it case in point this
is the brand new oneplus x it's going to
cost 249
249 off contract brand new in the box
everything three years ago 250 bucks
wouldn't get much of a smartphone at all
but even if you did it would be inferior
in pretty much every way while the
company who makes it focuses on bigger
and better things but that has changed a
lot over the last year and a half or so
and this phone well this is the latest
and greatest of that trend oneplus is
already pretty much known for cost
cutting and for your 250 bucks you are
getting a lot in this little guy so you
get a five-inch 1080p amoled display
that's a pretty good you know 441 pixels
per inch nice and crisp aquatic core
snapdragon 801 chip adreno 330 gpu 3
gigabytes of ram a 13 megapixel camera
with f 2.2 aperture on the back and a
surprisingly big 2 525 milliamp hour
battery now it is a baseline 16 gigabyte
model for the price but the sim card
tray actually has two slots for either
dual sim or you can go one nano sim and
one micro sd card slot so expandable
storage up to 128 more gigabytes so the
specs are definitely nice for the price
but equally important is industrial
design and how it feels in the hand and
that's really where the oneplus x
actually stands out from the rest in its
budget there's no plastic here the front
and back are panels of gorilla glass and
it has all grooved metal rail all the
way around the outside of the phone has
some nice weight to it it keeps the
alert slider on the left side from the
one plus two that we loved so much has
some chamfers and it curves the glass
right at the edges and overall it feels
like a really tight well constructed
almost familiar nearly high-end looking
smartphone it did feel a little bit
slippery to me with so much glass
obviously on the front and the back and
it's definitely a fingerprint magnet but
i think it kind of reminds me of the
sony xperia series mixed with a little
bit of nexus 4 a little bit of iphone 5s
with that completely flat back but all
those phones were much more expensive
than this one when they came out so the
specs and the build plus a build of
oxygen os that's optimized for the
hardware and you're looking at a pretty
sweet little package and oneplus throws
in some black wallpapers and a dark
theme in the os with true blacks to kind
of help you save a little bit of battery
life here and there toss in ambient
display and throw in some other features
like swiftkey built in and screen off
gestures and home screen features from
the oneplus 2 like shelf and you're
looking at an absolutely stacked
smartphone for a minimal price now this
is just the first impressions but you
can imagine you know with a smaller
1080p oled display and the relatively
huge battery it should last a while on a
charge even better i guess when android
6.0 comes to it with doze and the camera
was promising to me in person i'll of
course have to test that further but i'm
already thinking it'll be right up there
with smartphones way over its 250 dollar
price point so the value the focus on
value and getting a premium experience
at a low price continues and that's been
a serious trend for 2015. cheap phones
are getting good and good phones are
getting cheap thanks for watching and
i'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace